the Joe Rogan experience so what do you
spend your time doing these days do you
spend your time teaching seminars
coaching people like writing books what
do you what's the all of the above so I
I am staying I'm working on I teach some
special events for a strong first which
is my company the school of strength
so I teach seminars like strong
endurance the second wind and so on I
write books and I do some consulting but
what I really am trying to do is I'm
trying to build strong first you know
this school of strength my vision is
that more people want to become stronger
and strength will become cool strength
will become important and I'd like to
see that across the decades really do
you know the strength school now among a
small portion of the population do you
think that can actually change I hope so
I don't know I hope so
why would it change well we're working
at it maybe you'll do something about it
who knows but you know a friend of mine
said something interesting my friend
John he said today you have this very
small among young people a very small
fraction of the population this is super
tough guys or it is competing and I'm am
a and so on these Daredevils doing
extreme sports is so on and you have the
huge majority or just sitting doing this
or they go and do their little Pilates
thing or whatever they do their little
interval session and I just think the
society at large needs more just just
regular tough guys you know like the old
farmer or somebody like that and I think
that that needs to be more broad and
people need to understand that that I
hate this word fitness I just hate that
because it counters up images of just
all sorts of weird equipment and weird
exercises and foam rollers and all that
stuff you know you don't like foam
rollers it's not that I don't like foam
rollers it's a tool just like everything
else all right here's a problem a guy
comes in he spends
45 minutes and some fancy hickel's and
movement problem the hell's movement
prep and he's sitting around you know
rolling his butt in the foam roller and
then he does some other weird voodoo and
you know if he is injured and if he got
a prescription from his physical
therapist or doctor power to everybody
but if not and then finally is gonna
spend ten minutes doing some doing some
little nonsense get his heart rate up
and between sets is gonna be updating
his profile or whatever so the former
all you've got a it's got a place I'm
even gonna tell you like even doing any
of the corrective work something that
you need to do you should even separate
it from your training like don't
dishonor the lifting prop platform by
throwing a foam roller on it just do
somewhere else you know really yeah
don't dishonor don't I thought it was
just a natural thing to sort of work the
kinks out fine go working ma just do
somewhere else just don't do it by the
platform yet and don't ever step over a
barbell that's the most disrespectful
thing you can do really absolutely you
can't step over a bar bono in Russia get
beaten up and thrown out of the gym JB
you absolutely that seems excessive you
got to respect your van know you do and
stepping over a barbells disrespect
disrespect you have to go around it of
course of course how do I know this well
now you do I'd uh I'm trying to think
what I do I'm sure I've stepped over
barbells it will get even nobody ever
taught me that barbell get you yeah
really
Oh
[Applause]